we've looked at creating dashboards to
visualize the health of our systems
and automating them using the api and
terraform but today
i'm here to show you how to use the new
dashboard editor to visualize your cloud
monitoring data like never before
this is a stackdoctor
[Music]
before we start let's quickly review
what makes for a good dashboard
generally you want to focus on the key
signals that represent the health of
your service
these are covered in the monitoring
distributed systems chapter of the sre
book and we call them the golden signals
you can automate creating a dashboard
using the api or terraform
but today i want to show you how to use
the new dashboard editor in the cloud
console
right away you can see that the new
editor looks very different there's now
a list of widgets on the right to pick
from and a grid for laying out your
dashboard in the main panel
i specifically want to show you three
things the new widgets the new layout
options
and the new chart configuration options
let's dig in
start by adding a widget to the
dashboard the gauge widget finally gives
you a way to show a single number on a
dashboard as an indicator of health
for example you can use it to show mean
cpu limit use of all containers in the
workspace
one thing i really love about this new
widget is the ability to specify the
expected
range for the metric for example you can
set a warning threshold that will turn
the chart yellow
or a danger threshold that will turn it
red this gauge is a good way to
represent the saturation signal
if the containers on average are not
close to the limit there should be
plenty of capacity left
if you care about a specific service you
could filter for just the resources you
need
a gauge is a great way to see the
current value of a metric but it doesn't
show you any historical data if you need
that
you can use the new scorecard widget
this is a great way to visualize a
signal like latency
you can also use the warning and danger
thresholds to change the color of the
chart when the value exceeds the
threshold
this is great to let you know at a
glance that something is wrong
if you just want to see the current
state of a metric and what range it's in
the widget can be toggled to not show
you the time series chart behind it
this way you can see just the current
state of a metric and whether or not
it's within a good range
the last new widget i want to show you
is text yes text
you might be thinking sure you can now
add text boxes to dashboards that's
fine but here's the cool thing about
this
the text widget supports markdown which
lets you format the text
add links and generally make it look
like exactly what you want
this is a great way to add in-context
documentation to your dashboard
these new widgets are great but what can
you do with them let's have a look at
the new way to layout your dashboard
there are now two options for layout
grid the rows and columns you're used to
and mosaic the mosaic option lets you
size each chart individually and place
them where you want on the dashboard
you can use this to create a dashboard
like this showing your service traffic
as measured by request across the top
with the column of health indicators on
the left and documentation on the right
this is a great way to present
information
the last thing i want to show you is the
new way to configure the charts on the
dashboard
when creating a chart you now have the
option of switching between the basic
mode which should be enough for most
users most of the time
and advanced mode for example we can
switch to the advanced mode for a heat
map chart to specify exactly how we want
the data to be pre-processed
and which aligner to use if we need that
this gives you total control over how
the charts interpret
and present data thanks for joining me
today
we took a look at the new dashboard
editor and saw how to use it to create a
dashboard using the gauge
scorecard and text widgets we also
checked out the new layout options and
advanced chart configuration mode
now you're ready to use it to create
your dashboards and keep an eye on the
health of your services
thanks for watching and come back soon
for more this is a stackdoctor
stay healthy out there